[Musique]
va falloir ajouter en adaptation au
changement climatique pour les forêts
tout le monde ensemble le gouvernement
du Québec et les municipalités faire des
efforts pour continuer à augmenter le
milliard et demi
on le réitère là ça fait 5 ans qu'on le
demande d'avoir un plan du gouvernement
qui soit complet ce qu'on a pas par
rapport à la lutte au changement
climatique il va falloir qu'on
réfléchisse à comment s'équiper pour
cette nouvelle réalité le Premier
ministre était d'accord pour mettre un
terme à toute forme de financement
direct ou indirect au pétrolière il y a
un lien indéniable entre la saison des
feux de forêt que nous connaissons
présentement au Canada et l'utilisation
des combustibles nous devons réduire nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
c'est pourquoi nous allons supporter la
motion que le Bloc québécois déposé
aujourd'hui à cette chambre
alors les feux de forêt un peu partout
au pays ont ravivé le débat sur la lutte
contre les changements climatiques à
Québec comme à Ottawa les gouvernement
logo et Trudeau reconnaissent qu'il va
falloir en faire davantage pour
s'adapter à cette nouvelle réalité ce
que les oppositions réclament déjà
depuis longtemps Hélène Michel Paul
bonsoir à vous trois bonsoir retour Paul
on est content de vous retrouver merci
alors est-ce que ça va prendre des
crises comme celles qu'on vit en ce
moment pour que les gouvernements
agissent de façon plus décisive Michel
on va commencer un peu avec ce qui se
passe à Québec
de façon générale que ça soit Québec ou
ailleurs les gouvernements sont beaucoup
plus forts sur la réaction que sur la
prévention
j'entendais monsieur Trudeau il y a
quelques secondes qui nous disait il va
falloir qu'on commence à réfléchir mais
là je pense que la réflexion devrait
passer avancée pour que on commence à
agir mais honnêtement d'une fois à
l'autre le prenez par exemple la
dernière crise sur le verglas on avait
dit il fuir des fils il faut acheter des
génératrices pour les CHSLD ça a pas de
bon sens à ce que je sache là il y a pas
encore eu d'achat massif de génératrices
pour équiper les CHSLD la même chose
lors des inondations mais Saint-Paul on
s'était promis toutes sortes de choses
avec sincérité d'ailleurs mais les
priorités se bousculent et à un moment
donné il y a un autre feu au sens figuré
du terme qui s'allume quelque part et et
on change alors
de ne pas et l'autre question c'est qui
va payer là pour cette prévention là
déjà écoutez on est encore en plein
dedans puis monsieur le groupe les
municipalités commencent à se lancer la
balle d'un côté ou de l'autre à monsieur
Legault dit écoutez les contribuables
sont déjà assez taxés mais il y a de la
marge d'un municipalité de les
municipalités disent écoutez nous déjà
on voudrait élargir avoir d'autres
champs de taxation parce que l'impôt
fiscal ne l'impro dit
foncier ne suffit pas assumer nos
besoins alors personne veut payer quoi
alors est-ce que malgré toutes les
preuves qui s'accumulent et elle nous
arrive comme ça assez brutalement on
serait donc peut-être pas prêt encore à
changer nos modes de vie Hélène
ouais je le pense effectivement qu'on
n'est pas prêt Michel a raison on va
d'une crise à l'autre vers là
inondations feux de forêt à chaque fois
on fait des promesses un peu de sous
l'ombre qu'on oublie le lendemain dès
que la catastrophe est oubliée autant à
Québec à Ottawa les gouvernements
croient à l'importance de lutter contre
les changements climatiques mais ils
entretiennent l'illusion auprès des
citoyens des électeurs que cette lutte
pourra se faire sans perturber notre
petit confort individuel et c'est là
l'hypocrisie je pense il va falloir un
moment donné avoir cette conversation
d'adulte de dire écoutez il faut changer
profondément nos comportements
individuels aussi bien sûr qu'il faudra
s'attaquer au pétrolières mais ça ne
pourra pas faire toute le travail et je
pense par exemple à l'industrie
automobile vous avez en ce moment le
gouvernement fédéral et les
gouvernements de l'Ontario et du Québec
qui littéralement distribue des dizaines
des milliards de dollars pour faire
s'installer cette nouvelle industrie
automobile mais électrique bon bravo on
brûlera plus de l'essence on va prendre
de l'électricité à la place mais on ne
change toujours pas ce paradigme de
l'auto-solo on continue cette mauvaise
habitude de nord-américains de
s'attacher 2000 kg de ferraille sur le
dos chaque matin avant d'aller
travailler et et cette ferraille et ben
elle coûte les polluante à extraire à
transformer à déplacer etc alors on est
encore dans cette illusion qu'on peut
faire cette lutte au changement
climatique sans que ça nous affecte j'ai
eu grâce à la technologie
et j'ai un peu l'impression d'être dans
le film donc le coq quoi
si on roule à 100 000 $ puis on commence
à freiner on a beau freinait autant
qu'on veut
ça va prendre une certaine distance les
gros doigts agissent le gouvernement
Trudeau a imposé le taxe carbone de
gouvernement de François Lego qui
n'avait aucun plan sur le climat lors de
son élection en 2018 vient d'aller
chercher Michael Sabia pour
le président de Québec une politique de
barrage nucléaire et au lien assez
ambitieuse mais encore une fois si on
commence à freiner trop tard et s'il y a
un mur devant soi ça va pas forcément
aider malgré tout ce qu'on voit autour
de nous et tout ce qui brûle autour de
nous bon j'aimerais qu'on parle
maintenant de cette décision d'interdire
la tenue d'un événement entier
avortement d'un groupe religieux qui est
basé en Colombie-Britannique au Centre
des congrès de Québec une interdiction
qui crée un malaise à l'Assemblée
nationale il y a d'abord eu consensus
sur cette question et puis après
réflexion le Parti québécois et Québec
solidaire ont décidé de reculer sur
cette question alors qu'est-ce qu'il
faut penser de cette décision du
gouvernement Hélène ben écoutez c'est
une très mauvaise décision et j'espère
que le gouvernement reculera parce que
on s'aventure sur une pente extrêmement
glissante si le gouvernement s'arroche
le droit de déterminer qu'est-ce qu'on
peut dire et ce que l'on peut penser sur
les lieux qui lui appartiennent
pensons à d'autres cas de figure si la
mairesse de Montréal Valérie plante
décrétait que nous n'accueillerons plus
le Grand Prix de formulaire au parc
Jean-Drapeau qui est un parc municipal
au nom des changements climatiques
imaginez le tollé imaginez un
hypothétique gouvernement à Québec
solidaire qui dirait on fait plus de
salon de l'auto dans nos palais des
congrès justement au nom de ces mêmes
changements climatiques ou un
gouvernement libéral qui dirait on va
pas permettre à Maxime Bernier de tenir
son congrès dans nos locaux dans les
locaux du Palais des Congrès parce qu'on
n'aime pas ses idées écouter c'est
extrêmement
glissant comme politique alors il y a
des gens qui diront oui mais à ce compte
là madame buzetti voilà on pourrait
faire des congrès de sur la bestialité
ou congrès de la
réalité c'est que il existe des lois et
la bestialité est interdite le langage
le langage haineux envers des groupes
identifiables et interdit aussi ce sont
ça les paramètres il existe une telle
chose que la liberté d'expression être
Provis ce n'est pas interdit donc bravo
aux autres partis qui ont su reculés le
Parti québécois d'abord puis Québec
solidaire mais en même temps on comprend
que pour le gouvernement c'est pas
interdire qu'ils prennent la parole ou
qui se rassemblent ailleurs c'est
interdire qu'il se rassemblent dans ce
centre des congrès de Québec qui on l'a
appris tous j'imagine avec cette affaire
appartient donc au gouvernement du
Québec Paul
oui justement je connais très bien
ce centre des congrès de Québec je le
fréquente depuis 35 ans je l'ai jamais
pris pour une haut lieu de la pensée de
l'État québécois
si
des manifestations ou des des hôteliers
veulent tenir un congrès c'est pas
l'État québécois qui prend une position
et donc ça aurait dû être assez évident
que l'État n'est pas insulté par le
présence de ces gens-là que l'État n'a
pas grand chose à voir c'est ce sont des
salles qu'on loue
comme il a dit si jamais il y avait des
des extrémistes qui prenaient je sais
pas trop la violence ou quelque chose de
genre il y a des lois spécifiques pour
ce genre de choses mais évoquer l'état
profond ou la philosophie profonde les
caractéristiques fondamentales du Québec
contient des déserts
un peu pour s'amuser c'est pas sérieux
et et
il faut aussi dire au début qui sont
souvent appelés à voter ou après en
position à l'unanimité qu'il faut se
méfier de l'unanimité c'est assez rare
dans la société il devrait être aussi
rare dans l'Assemblée nationale du
Québec